i want to turn to my right and welcome
our in-studio guest loved him in the
movie
horrible bosses and so much more it's
always sunny in philadelphia fantastic
show and now amazon studios i want you
back it's available for streaming right
now on prime video in time for
uh valentine's day week it's charlie day
good to see you sir good to see you so
you're strangers who meet each other
just after you're you get broken up with
by other people and you're trying to get
revenge for each other absolutely look
it's a classic romantic comedy setup you
know what i mean it's just uh
typical rom-com stuff and i always think
you know all right
i'm doing a rom-com where do i go a
sports show you know it's just a natural
smooth but honestly fantastic charlie
day man i got to tell you man uh charlie
day here on the rich eisen show we just
saw a clip of i want you back but go
ahead
explain everybody what this uh this bad
boy is about i love this movie and by
the way i don't know if you care about
reviews but the reviews are raves and
fantastic yeah for me that's rare um
except for sunny people like sunny but
um
it's it's just a romantic comedy i i
meet jenny slate we've both been broken
up with by our exes and we say hey let's
let's uh lean on each other to try to
win them back and
uh some comedy ensues some romance
ensues it's a great date night movie uh
but it's just also wickedly funny and a
good story right and so uh but you also
find out through social media that the
your exes have since moved on yes which
is something i never had to experience
it was never for you charlie dating in
the social media age and i don't think i
would have handled it well
yeah yeah stop out there because you
used to find out that people broke up or
you you know in high school or college
through you know just usually just
talking to people not like in the palm
of your hand
you might get a phone call you could do
that yeah you might get a phone call and
like you had to pick up because the
phone was ringing you didn't know who it
was right and then you found out you
were broken up with you know that was
probably the
most ruthless way but it was face to
face that was the way to do it yeah i
like it so
you're not your typical as you were just
pointing out you're not your typical
romance affair but it is kind of a nice
valentine's day type uh movie that you
got going on here right i think it's
great movie i i think people enjoy it
whether you like romantic movies or not
in fact i've had a lot of people
speaking social media reaching out to me
and saying
i don't usually dig romantic comedies
and this is the favorite one i've ever
seen so
you know i think it's good fantastic
it's streaming right now on uh on prime
video uh jenny slate scott eastwood
who's a very handsome man
um he's in this film as well so it's a
good cast the whole thing yeah yeah yeah
mr eastwood young mr eastwood okay very
good yeah not old eastwood yeah it's
okay uh either way uh eastwood is a
fantastic name and i want you back again
is available for for streaming on prime
video so did you see uh the super bowl
this past weekend charlie oh yeah i did
see the super bowl and um i did the most
responsible thing i've ever done what is
this i got myself a bunch of
non-alcoholic beer because i knew i was
going to want to watch beer and i mean
drink beer watch super bowl yes but i
had my kid and i had to drive home and
then i had to get him up early for
school
and so i was like you know what and it
was it felt just the same but then when
i got in my car i was like
nice i'm not going to get arrested
i killed my kid you know like this was
this was
it was a good move it's a win-win yeah
so that's the sign of getting old and uh
yeah like the game i i like the game you
know a couple calls that like the pretty
obvious face mask they didn't call it oh
my god he did damn near that how did he
miss that like that's
like i can see maybe something where the
ball where the ball isn't where there's
a pack of guys yeah it's just two guys
there you know two face masks
100 million people at home 100 million
people at home everyone sees it but
i don't know it's all we get the luxury
of like they play stuff back they slow
it down you get a bird's eye view right
i'm sure it's happening so fast but
how do you miss that i don't know that
was pretty horrible and then you know i
i i was there and jaylen ramsey who was
the guy who had his face mask damn near
ripped off his helmet he just gave the
only reaction that you could because
normally when somebody
uh doesn't get a penalty called when
it's obvious they'll go nuts yeah he
just went he like the thing we said on
the show there he looked like that john
travolta jeff
pulp fiction kind of like you know which
way do i go like yeah is this what is
this what we're doing now
we're just going to let people get face
masks yeah that's that's all he did um
so where were you like who's like what
what's this is
i was invited to the super bowl but i
got a wife with a broken wrist right now
and she's out of commission so i'm like
in dad mode uh solo doubting pretty much
most the time until she heals and so i
had to stay home with a kid but we went
over a buddy's house they got a son his
age they looked at my boys
situation yeah yeah and while the dads
watch football the dads and one drinks
fake beer watch super bowl okay have you
ever been to a super bowl charlie day
i've actually never been to the super
bowl yeah is it all it's is it all it's
cracked up to be like i kind of like
being at home i like that i get to watch
it from home well the thing is is that
now with the new stadiums like the one
here in los angeles there is a
monster-sized television set that's
hanging above the stadium
so you kind of get a little bit of that
you don't get the commercials if you're
into the commercials if you like those
if you think those are funny yeah you
don't get those in the game no you know
i don't think they're funny
and i've been in there i've been in
there man
which one would you wear not this year i
was the year before i did a bunch of
like commercials for tide but uh yeah
i'm always like man they're never great
including yours yeah
it's fine you know it's fine
fine it's good okay um
i went to a game with a cowboys game
yeah that is the biggest jumbotron yeah
i've ever seen in my life yeah they they
i can barely see the field that's i
there was the one super bowl that was
there
and i'm watching the game on the tv and
i think to myself at one point i'm like
i am so lucky to be at a super bowl why
am i not watching the actual people why
am i watching it like i'm sitting in a
living room it's just your eyes just go
straight up to it you know i mean if
that thing drops i don't care how many
helmets these guys got on like that's it
you got
you got a squashed team two teams you
don't need a concussion protocol there
no you know you're out you're off the
field yeah you're oh yeah uh hopefully
you know yeah that doesn't but and and
now it's it hangs so low like punters
actually hit it with the football like
that happens but this is the new state
have you been to the new stadium
it's amazing it really is just i felt
sorry for odell coming out of the game
and uh you know not getting to be
it's a piece of me and of course you
know what do i know but that's thinking
like do you not try to like tough it out
like
you're you're standing you're moving
around i know like what am i talking
about i'm not you know i can't
i can't take it but this piece of me is
like this is a super bowl this is the
game yeah yeah and if you can move your
legs
yeah don't you get in there but i guess
he was he was out well i mean is that
what you say to your wife with the with
the wrist injury so what you say to her
right now no no no because i'm scared of
her i don't know
so like you know you're like hotel yeah
your knee is hardly attached because of
you know that acl thing why don't you
get out there and your wife's sitting at
home like you got to take the kid
because my wrist is yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know you're not going to the super
bowl
but
i don't know get in the game man you
know finish a game
charlie day here uh on the rich eisen
show so uh what's your favorite uh
devito story you got one that you can
you can lay in yeah i know you we've
talked about sunny here on the show
before with you but
um we had devito here uh one time and it
was one of my favorite
segments and just the conversations
because i could have gone in a million
different directions were you able to
follow what he was saying well
devito talks devito i can translate it
now but he can it's like a 70s thing
like these guys where he like gives you
half sentences like yeah you know you
know all the guys jack plus you get a
little coke and then boom you so it's a
party go
what
what are you saying you know like he's
like
i was there but then you know they they
do the whole thing actually
my best my favorite to vietnam story yes
although this is not one that i was
present for was he told me a story about
he's like charlie you know i went to
this one party in the 80s
and uh
you know i walk in the party and it's
like cocaine everywhere i'm like all
right and he goes they got everybody's
name spelled out in cocaine on on these
glass tables
and uh you know there's mine devito and
then i look over
and schwarzenegger's eyes are like he's
smiling because his name's like 30 miles
long look at this danny look how long my
name is
that was my favorite thing
yeah was it script or was it print do we
know i mean
cursive i think yeah yeah
very much that's impressive that's an
artist that is yeah that's how i
imagined it but probably like
right razor blade lines
something up with that yeah
he confirmed to us that he does in fact
have most of the time uh a trampoline
around him like he likes to trampoline
oh yeah
you've is that a true story yeah he has
trampolines backyard and i have seen him
on the trampoline what is it like to see
danny tavito on a trampoline charlie day
it's like you know dropping a bowling
ball on a trampoline
seeing it bounce around
uh
i don't know i just thought it must be
the wildest thing you know what we could
all learn something from danny because
he it was he's his mid-70s yeah and he's
pretty like mobile athletic like the
stuff we make him do on sunny yeah we
put this guy through the ringer you know
we like he's tearing out of couches
naked and we're like crashing him
through windows and
how did you get him to do it to begin
with did you need to twist his arm a
little bit no
it wasn't until like the last few years
where he was like hey guys maybe this
one you know i keep my shirt on we're
like all right fine danny but uh no he's
just game you know he's comfortable
whatever i love it charlie day here on
the rich eisen show okay so now what's
uh what's your handicap these days what
do you got for me uh well
it's going up um but it's i'm out of
five now uh but i was down with i was
down to a three i got down to a one for
like a month and i was like this is no
good because i can't bet anyone anymore
because i'm gonna lose
but i had a few like even par rounds and
a couple under par rounds and i was like
i figured the game out and which was the
dumbest thing ever to think
uh because now the high 70s and the low
80s have reared their head back in but
did you really think you figured the
game out
yeah yeah i thought okay well if i just
keep a square
my club face fairly square through
impact yes and just keep turning through
and then you know just avoid double
bogeys and
try to put where you have and then make
the occasional birdie that's it and then
you know you go out one day and you're
like i don't know where the ball's going
that's such a jacked up game it really
is it it's just so mental
it's so mental so
mental you know and like my favorite
story about this was
years and years ago dan marino okay
tried for the us open and missed you
know you know i guess as an as an
amateur what have you tried missed it
couldn't make it
almost did but didn't and his quote
afterwards is he didn't think he had the
the mental
sharpness
that was required and i'm like this is a
guy whose job is at one point in time to
spot where mike singletary is to make
sure that he knows pre-snap what he
might do he's got a 300-pound man
running full speed out that's what i'm
saying like and to know like he needs to
make sure his receiver that was planning
to go right this and then that now he's
going to do this and then that make that
decision prior to a snap as a clock's
ticking down that guy says
that he needs to have a better
concentration level for golf and it's
just like what you know what
it's got it's guys like that they're
used to being reactionary in the moment
right someone's coming at them they
react and golf has so many moments of
stillness right it's you over a nervy
little chip or putt and your four
buddies standing around and you don't
want to be embarrassed but i do think
the better you
you know the more reactionary you make
it the better you're gonna play right
which hard to remember to do but kind of
make it like target oriented which is
like all right there's that tree over
there just get the ball over there
there's okay there's that side of the
green just go for that
and same with chipping and putting but
it's real easy to get in your head and
be like i got you know we're slowing up
the group behind me or or we just played
through someone uh it's so much about
like ego and embarrassment like it's
right that's what messes you up who's
the guy you'd watch
more than anybody right now who's the
guy you like on the table
patrick canelay
there's a steal on this guy last year he
was lights out right i mean that playoff
against bryson did you see that him and
bryson unbelievable out of control and
and it's just that right it's like you
hear him talk about it he's like i try
to get athletic with it
and just
you know
it's a focus thing where bryson is very
technical and he's great at it right
he's got all his numbers in his head and
he stands over ball and he's like he's
he's doing like pie charts
right
i know
and then and then it's but then they'll
then then he'll just bomb it
and say i'll just deal with it when i
find it you know what i mean yeah right
so i don't get it like sometimes he's
doing like the beautiful mind stuff in
his head yeah you're talking about this
arm angle needs to be one degree in a
different direction right and then
sometimes let's say screw it i'm just
gonna bomb it i'll find it and then
we'll figure it out from there all i
gotta do is if i get it on the green in
certain levels length and a certain spot
and two shots i got a shot here you know
i think nine times out of ten you're
gonna hit it better when you do that and
then
also when you finish your round you're
gonna be like i had more fun because i
was out there being
a little bit more athletic right and
less sort of calculating but i don't
know then you bomb it right into a tree
and you're like damn it do you like a
beverage out there do you do that or no
because you got it it depends on the
game like if i if i'm playing a pretty
serious game or we got some money on it
i probably well unless i'm playing like
crap and then yeah beer might help but
the swing oil yeah it depends if if i
got somewhere to go but i like a beer at
the turn you do i do yeah well you you
don't i i'm i'm not serious about it so
i'm i'm i'm just depending on if it's
five o'clock somewhere um i'm going for
it yeah a little i i'm not a beer guy so
i'm gonna go like vodka it's like
straight
you know certainly if i'm not driving
home i'm just going for it and i might
be useless by like 14 or 15. yeah i'm
not bombed but i'm just i'm
i'm i don't have that i don't have that
level of concentration
the place we play and i know you play
this you you get a drink there they're
going to it real stiff
there's been a bloody mary that snuck up
on me there where i was like it was
bloody i can't come home for another
three hours i'm so sorry i've made a
mistake i'll take a nap in the car
oh man i was so bad when i tried out
there to
thankfully i got in uh i was so bad uh i
don't want to call him out on the air
but he was you know he's part of the the
the uh deciders he said to me at one
point he goes you know we have tennis
too
that sounds like a that's how bad it is
whose initials are bl
is that right am i right right guy
yes sir yeah you know you know i know
that because he told me that because i
had to change the same thing yeah i had
a case of the shanks for a while and i
was just like that's his stock line well
i've never heard that one before
yeah there's tennis too
thankfully i'm in i'm worse than tennis
so yeah
i don't know the concentration level
that's why i talk about it for a living
um charlie day i want you back it's
available on amazon prime video right
now was released last friday it is
available for everybody uh just in time
again for uh valentine's week great to
see you charlie yeah good to see you too
man let's do this more often and i'd
love to now that i'm done with football
tee it up if you're around yeah hit me
up let's play let's do it
it's underscore charlie
underscore day on twitter why are that's
not me that's i'm not on twitter that's
not on youtube on twitter i know that's
a little monster
are you on instagram i'm on instagram
charlie day official
probably
all right screw the social media
everybody go see i want you back on uh
prime video right now with charlie day
jenny slate and more hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here